olivier crown bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl france pour revenir sur
ces discussions qui ont repris entre
washington et les talibans les talibans
qui avaient exprimé leur souhait avant
cette réunion d'avoir de bonnes
relations avec les pays du bout du monde
leur objectif premier finalement c'est
la levée des sanctions américaines alors
que le pays est au bord d'une crise
humanitaire
effectivement je crois que la première
des priorités de du gouvernement du
régime taliban actuellement sénat levée
des sanctions pour pouvoir renouer tout
simplement avec la communauté
internationale avec l'afghanistan c'est
face à une situation économique est
catastrophique après 40 ans de guerre
avec des robinets si je puis dire qu'ils
sont coupés depuis leur prise de pouvoir
mi-août donc leur première priorité
c'est ça bien évidemment il ya une
question de reconnaissance de leur
gouvernement de leur régime qui suit
cette première priorité est donc c'est
cette quête clark que le gouvernement
tellement cherche auprès des acteurs
internationaux et auprès des américains
bien entendu outils qui vont rencontrer
de nouveau à doigts parce que ce sont
des discussions pour parler qui en
réalité ont continué depuis continué
pendant un moment donc c'est une énième
rencontre donc voilà ce que viennent
négocier les talibans le bus tout
simplement améliorer la situation
économique du pays érotique est
réellement catastrophique et en retour
ce que cherchent les américains parce
que vous devez également
ne négocie pas pour rien on était face à
une situation qui n'ont peut-être pas
voulu mais toujours est il que la
question de la sécurité internationale
toujours à sebring
donc une lutte contre le terrorisme
effectivement prioritaire pour les
américains quittent être moins
regardants sur les questions des droits
de l'homme notamment des femmes on le
sait installer des gages
attendu de la part des talibans
absolument les américains je pense là la
priorité des américains c'est la
question sécuritaire c'est à dire que
les talibans ennemis d'hier en quelque
sorte peuvent potentiellement devenir
les alliés de circonstance des alliés
objectifs d'aujourd'hui vous savez que
l'afghanistan
le régime taliban lutte contre l'état
islamique qui était pieds toujours
présents en afghanistan qui je le
rappelle est une organisation terroriste
et rival des talibans que les talibans
vont d'ailleurs combattu sur le terrain
donc les américains à se retrouve avec
les talibans
ironie de l'histoire alliés pour lutter
contre l'état islamique qui est
effectivement toujours présents en
afghanistan
on sait ce que c'est cette garantie là
que vient chercher les américains dont
une garantie que l'afghanistan
redevienne pas un havre pour les
terroristes une base pour les
terroristes en l'occurrence les
terroristes cette fois ci sont l'état
islamique qui sont les années à la fois
de la communauté internationale en
général et du gouvernement et du régime
taliban est en place à kaboul et
pourquoi cette alliance elle serait
possible aujourd'hui avec les talibans
je dirais que les américains n'ont pas
réellement le choix des talibans ont
pris le pouvoir après 20 ans de lutte
près vingt ans de guerre donc ça c'est
un fait donc donc il va falloir composer
un moment donné ou à un autre avec
vernement talibans ce soit d'avoir les
américains les russes et chinois presque
toutes les puissances régionales qui ont
des intérêts plus ou moins stratégiques
dans la région
donc il va falloir comme je disais
composer avec ce régime taliban faire
avec et vu qu'il y a pire que le un pire
que les talibans si je puis dire donc en
l'occurrence l'état islamique est
l'ennemi tout le monde qui est une
organisation terroriste qui ne cherchent
pas réellement à prendre le pouvoir on
sépare clairement leurs objectifs sans
le son sont différents ils sont
davantage dans une logique de jihad
international conquis
ils menacent un peu tout le monde je
dirais et dans ce cadre là dans une
situation comme ça et bien les talibans
peuvent être un allié objectif un allié
de circonstance pour stabiliser le pays
est bien évident que qu un afghanistan
stable dans l'intérêt de tout le monde
et si
pouvoir à kaboul en l'occurrence le
dramont talibans être en mesure d'avoir
un afghanistan stable et bien soit ça
sera donc les alliés avec lesquels il va
falloir composer pour donc une question
de sécurité qui passe avant si les
questions de droits de l'homme si je
puis dire les questions de droits de
l'homme du gouvernement inclusif qui ont
fait partie des critères les américaines
de la musique dans nationale en général
sont bien évidemment sur la liste mais
la première chose c'est cette garantie
d'une sécurité
[Musique]
peuvent potentiellement fournir les
tells tant inspiré du classique à
seulement
parce que vous rappeliez cette volonté
de conquête a reconnu de l'état
islamique ce qui n'est pas le cas des
talibans ils sont passés de volonté dans
la région
disons que le mouvement taliban est un
mouvement effectivement
islamistes djihadistes etc mais qui
avait un objectif est un programme qui
était purement nationale à ne pas dire
qu'il n'avait pas d' influence au delà
de leurs frontières le mouvement
tellement existe au pakistan mais c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose mais le
programme est l'objectif des taliban
afghans s'étaient que la conquête du
pouvoir actuel de kaboul et il a pris ce
que la conquête de deux l'afghanistan à
au delà des frontières c'est pas un
programme tel que tels qu'al-qaïda à
l'époque un al qaïda s'étaient djihad
international c'était voilà un petit peu
comme entrant fois là-haut le champ
mondiale quoi
on les les premiers communiste donc les
talibans ne s'inscrivent pas dans ce
programme là l'objectif c'était prendre
le pouvoir à kaboul contrôler
l'afghanistan et sa élisant réussi
voilà donc leur programme lors leur
objectif s'arrête là s'arrête aux
frontières de l'afghanistan ce qui n'est
pas le cas de l'état islamique leur
programme c'est le cas les chats
mondiale etc ça va bien au delà les
frontières afghane wire ça ces
transnationales 6-3 alors des
discussions entre washington et les
talibans aujourd'hui les talibans qui
demande aussi de l'aide à l'aide de
l'union européenne notamment pour
garantir le fonctionnement des aéroports
aujourd'hui quelle est la posture de
l'europe par rapport aux taliban
dont moment c'est encore un postulant
dit je dirais plus ou moins timide
maintenant effectivement il ya eu sans
pleurer qu'il ya eu des discussions pour
la réouverture d'une entité diplomatique
de l'union européenne qui sera
probablement un format assez réduit mais
toujours est il que ça pourrait être une
antenne probablement à kaboul
donc pour le moment c'est assez timide
mêlée mais il est assez vraisemblable de
petit à petit l'organiste ans devra soit
inscrire au sein de la communauté
internationale avec les différentes
puissances régionales où l'union
européenne vont devoir d'une manière ou
d'une autre directement ou indirectement
renouer avec avec ceux qui sont au
pouvoir à kaboul je dirais de facto ne
serait ce que pour ces questions
sécurité internationales qui ont été
évoqués ainsi nous voulons un
afghanistan stable qui permette
qui permettent cette stabilité dans tout
le monde cherche que tout le monde
cherche des biens il va falloir que ce
gouvernement taliban qui puisse
sanctionner tout simplement et pour cela
il va falloir à un moment donné fournir
une aide substantielle une aide
internationale rouvrir en quelque sorte
les robinets pour permettre à kaboul
dont aux talibans de asseoir leur
pouvoir et de ils ont su devenir aux
besoins de la population entier dans
l'isère terrible et une stabilisait tout
simplement le pays c'est de ça dont il
s'agit quoi merci beaucoup olivier crown
pour votre éclairage ce matin sur rtl
france je le rappelle vous êtes ancien
officier aux français en afghanistan
ex-conseiller politique à kaboul